>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SUDDENLY THERE ARE
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR THEIR
PARTY'S PRESIDENTIAL NOMINATION
AND DISAGREEMENTS BETWEEN THEM.
ONE THING MANY AGREE ON IS
EMBRACING THE FOREIGN POLICY
AGENDA OF BILL CRYSTAL IN SYRIA
OR VENEZUELA, AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE UNITED STATES TO ENTER
CONFLICTS AROUND THE WORLD THEY
SUPPORT IT.
TULSI GABBARD WANTS TO KEEP
AMERICA OUT OF POINTLESS FOREIGN
WARS AND HAS BEEN ATTACKED IN
WASHINGTON.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
YOU HAVE BEEN CRITICIZED FOR
COMING ON THE SHOW.
WE DISAGREE ON MOST THINGS.
YOU ARE A PROGRESSIVE.
ONE PLACE I ADMIRE YOUR COURAGE
IS YOUR UNWILLINGNESS TO GO
ALONG WITH THE FOREIGN POLICIES
IN WASHINGTON.
YOU ARE ATTACKED.
>> I AM A SOLDIER OF THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD.
I SERVED ON 2 MIDDLE EAST
DEPLOYMENTS.
I KNOW FIRST HANTHE COST OF WAR.
I SERVED ON THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND THE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE.
I HAVE SEEN HOW SELF-SERVING,
POWERFUL POLITICIANS FROM BOTH
PARTIES HAVE CONTINUED THIS
FOREIGN POLICY REGIME CHANGE WAR
VIEW, WHERE THEY THINK WE THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD BE ACTING
AS THE POLICEMEN OF THE WORLD
AND CONTINUE TO GO AROUND AND
OVERTHROW AND TOPPLING DICTATORS
OR COUNTRIES WHO WE DON'T LIKE,
COSTING US THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
TRILLION DOLLARS IN THE PROCESS.
CAUSING MORE SUFFERING IN THE
COUNTRIES WHERE WE GO AND WAGE
THESE WARS AND BY THE WAY
UNDERMINING OUR OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY AS WE ARE SEEING
PLAYING OUT IN COUNTRIES LIKE
NORTH KOREA WHERE KIM JONG-UN
HAS STATED HE IS HOLDING ON TO
NUCLEAR WEAPONS AS HIS ONLY
DETERRENT TO THE UNITED STATES
COMING IN AND WAGING A REGIME
CHANGE WAR IN NORTH KOREA.
WHILE I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FACT THE SUMMIT ENDED WITHOUT AN
AGREEMENT, BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SEE DENUCLEARIZATION, IT'S NOT
SURPRISING BECAUSE OF THIS
POLICY, THIS REGIME CHANGE
POLICY.
LEADERS IN BOTH PARTIES HERE IN
WASHINGTON HAD PERPETUATED OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS SO
INTERESTING IS THAT WORLD VIEW,
THE REGIME CHANGE, IF IT
WORKED -- AT ONE TIME I THOUGHT
IT MADE SENSE.
WE HAD ALMOST 20 YEARS OF IT.
IT HASN'T WORKED.
WHY WOULD PEOPLE STILL SUPPORT
THAT?
>> WELL, THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MILITARY
INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX THAT BENEFITS
OFF OF THESE CONTINUED REGIME
CHANGE WARS AND THOSE IN
WASHINGTON WHO INVESTED THEIR
ENTIRE CAREERS BUILT ON
CONTINUING TO WAGE THESE WARS.
THE MOST UNFORTUNATE THING IS
THEY SELL THEM UNDER THE GUISE
OF HUMANITARIANISM TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO WANT TO DO
GOOD THINGS AND HELP PEOPLE WHO
ARE SUFFERING.
BUT NOT POINTING OUT THE FACT
AND FACING THE TRUTH IN EACH
EXAMPLE OF REGIME CHANGE LED BY
THE UNITED STATES RESULTED IN
FAR MORE SUFFERING FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO THEY ARE SUPPOSEDLY
TRYING TO HELP.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
MOTIVES.
YOU CAN LOOK AT CORPORATE GREED
AND WHO BENEFITS FINANCIALLY
WARS.
SELF-SERVING POWERFUL
POLITICIANS AND LEADERS IN BOTH
PARTIES.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE BEEN
ATTACKED AND I WON'T MAKE YOU
RELIVE IT.
INCLUDING BY SOME PEOPLE I KNOW
WHO SHOULD KNOW BETTER.
NOBODY HAS ENGAGED YOU IN THE
ARGUMENT YOU JUST MADE.
THEY DISMISSED YOU AS SUCKING UP
TO THIS DICTATOR AND YOU ARE A
BAD PERSON.
HAS ANYONE DEBATED YOU ON THE
POINTS YOU ARE MAKING?
>> NO, NO.
CONSTANTLY I SEE AGAIN PEOPLE
FROM BOTH PARTIES INSTEAD
RESORTING TO NAME CALLING OR
SUPERFICIAL ATTACKS BECAUSE THEY
REFUSE TO ENGAGE ON THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS ARGUMENT ABOUT
WHY THEY CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
AND TRY TO WAGE THESE REGIME
CHANGE WARS IGNORING THE
CONSEQUENCES ON THE PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRIES AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE REALITY IS THESE WARS ARE
COSTING THE TAXPAYERS TRILLION
DOLLARS, DOLLARS THAT SHOULD BE
HERE.
THAT SHOULD REMAIN IN OUR
POCKETS OR INVESTED IN
REBUILDING OUR CRUMLING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE NEEDS OF
OUR PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I JUST WANT TO SAY WE
DISAGREE ON MANY THINGS.